would the office of work of Seth Rogen
playing one of the most memorable
characters or would it have been super
bad TV and movie history could have
looked very different that these actors
nailed these auditions
after El James's 50 Shades of Gray
novels dominated the sales charts and to
capture the pop culture Zeitgeist the
time came for the salacious book series
to be turned into a Blockbuster movie of
course with all the raunchiness
mentioned in the story the roles of
Christian Gray and Anastasia Steele
would require high levels of nudity and
boldness from the actors selected for
the parts even so there were many
performers who are ready to strip down
for the next big Hollywood franchise
Pretty Little Liar star Lucy Hale
disclosed to Associated Press that she
auditioned for the part of Anastasia she
explained it wasn't actual scenes from
the movie but it was a very sexually
forward monologue and I didn't really
even know what I was saying in the
audition while the role of Anastasia
went to Dakota Johnson Hale appreciated
the auditioning experience as it forced
her to step out of her comfort zone and
challenge herself as a performer
at times being an actor is similar to
any other job in the sense that if
someone is too good at something they
will never get promoted thus the reality
that John Krasinski lived for many years
while the role of Jim Halpert and the
office may have turned him into a
household name it also Typecast him in
the eyes of many no matter what
Krasinski tried to do he was always seen
as Jim I don't think any of them
actually know my real name
nonetheless during an appearance on the
Ellen Degeneres Show he revealed that he
still took a shot at auditioning for the
part of Steve Rogers in Captain America
the First Avenger at first Krasinski
joked that he stepped away after Chris
Hemsworth walked in but in all
seriousness the actor revealed that he
had the opportunity to try on the
Captain America suits and gave the best
performance he could ultimately the
filmmakers decided to go with Chris
Evans instead Kozinski would eventually
join the MCU when he appeared as Reed
Richards and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness
Robert Pattinson doesn't seem to lose
many roles in fact there's even a
long-standing joke that if he and Henry
Cavill auditioned for the same part
patterns some will come out on top this
Rings a specially true considering how
Pattinson reportedly beat caval to the
roles of Cedric Diggory in Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire and Edward Cullen
in Twilight yet there is one director
who decided against pouring some rpat's
magic into his Film Production opting
instead for a certain MCU actor and
Scott Pilgrim Vs the World Scott needs
to battle seven of Ramona's Exes in his
quest to be with her one of them is
Lucas Lee a jug-like character who oozes
Corners in a Vanity Fair retrospective
of the 2010 film director Edgar Wright
mentioned how Pattinson auditioned for
the part of Lucas which eventually went
to Chris Evans he said I remember it
vividly he did a much more intense read
of it as well obviously Robert is an
incredible actor and someone who would
love to work with now but it was a very
different take from what Chris did
for too long Jake Gyllenhaal was seen as
the almost man in Hollywood despite
being widely regarded as one of the most
talented actors of his generation he
missed out on pivotal roles because of
timing or other factors outside of his
control a big one was Spider-Man when
Toby Maguire and Sony did A Dance about
whether he would be back as Peter Parker
for Spider-Man 2 Jill and all had been
in the running to replace Maguire if the
actor vacated the web he was also linked
with the role of Batman in the past with
the same outcome yet there was an
audition that Gyllenhaal lost and it was
probably for the better appearing on The
Tonight Show starring Jimmy Fallon the
actor spoke about the time he auditioned
to be Frodo in The Lord of the Rings in
a hilarious recount of his audition
Gyllenhaal explained how he arrived
without much knowledge of what he was
supposed to do including the accent for
the character the Reed required the
actor to take out the one ring and react
to it however he didn't do much and
spoke in his regular voice reporter lead
director Peter Jackson told him to get
new agents after the audition ended
little house down there
in 2010 Emma Stone was on her way to the
top she might not have been the A-list
award-winning actor she is now but she
was attracting all the right attention
thanks to her performances in Zombieland
the Rucker and Superbad despite all of
the positive Buzz she didn't receive a
role in a film she wanted to be a part
of Alice in Wonderland in an interview
with variety Stone and Timothy chalamet
discuss some of the setbacks had
experience in their careers and
Charlemagne revealed he didn't get a
role in Miss Peregrine Home for Peculiar
Children Stone opened up about until she
also missed out on a Tim Burton movie
she said Tim Burton's a Crusher oh my
god well now auditioned for Alice in
Wonderland and not getting a Tim Burton
movie is really devastating while Stone
didn't specify which part she auditioned
for it was likely for the lead character
Alice a role that ultimately went to Mia
vashikovska
Marvel's Iron Fist show didn't exactly
Electrify viewers there were many
criticisms over the storyline and a
distincter lack of fight training
demonstrated by the lead staff in Jones
when the series dropped though there was
one major highlight Lewis Tan's turn as
Joe Chang after witnessing his
performance many fans believed tan
should have been cast as Danny Rand
instead especially considering he had
auditioned for that very part the
Goodwill puts out on the radar of Marvel
Studios though considering how small the
role of Cheng was he could have easily
been cast another character in a later
project the opportunity arrived when he
auditioned for the title role in shanxi
and the legend of the ten Rings speaking
to ET Tam revealed his disappointment
when he found out he didn't get the part
I just lost a crazy job uh really really
high caliber level job while some was
initially very disappointed it wasn't
all bad news as that one door closed
another opened and welcomed him as the
lead character Carl Jung in the 2021
Mortal Kombat film
it's difficult to imagine anyone else
but Amelia Clark as Daenerys Targaryen
as with any other production though
there were other actors considered
during the audition process one of them
was one division star Elizabeth Olsen
during an interview with vulture Olsen
revealed when I first started working I
just auditioned for everything because I
like auditioning and I auditioned for
Khaleesi I forgot that it was the most
awkward audition I'd ever had Olsen
elaborated on the process saying she
read from a scene that appeared toward
the end of Game of Thrones season 1. at
the time there was uncertainty
surrounding the direction of daenerys's
accent so Olson performed both American
and British versions for the audition in
her Minds it was totally terrible but it
hasn't stopped her from becoming a fan
of the show even if she failed to be
cast in it
the live-action version of Beauty and
the Beast features a star-studded curse
one of the standouts in the movie is
Luke Evans who brings a boat for Gaston
to life whether it's through song dance
or festicuffs Evan cements himself as a
Pitch Perfect antagonist here before
Evans received the call for the Pod
though another popular British actor was
in the mix Idris Elba revealed in an
interview with Jess Cagle that he
personally phoned up the filmmakers for
the chance to audition as he explained I
Honestly Love musicals I auditioned for
Beauty and the Beast I really did for
Gaston I called and said listen I once
in so somewhere they have a tape of me
singing Elba is a musician so it should
come as no surprise to anyone that he
would love to take a crack at a musical
but sadly his take on Gaston and never
had a chance to come to life
for many Star Wars as a holy grail of
Cinema everyone wants to be part of the
universe in some shape or form which is
why so many famous actors came here with
Stormtroopers but one performer who
wanted something a little more was
Michael B Jordan the actor revealed he
auditioned for the part of Finn and Star
Wars the Force awakens which ultimately
went to John boyega speaking on Just for
variety with Mark Malkin Jordan listed
his Star Wars audition as the worst of
his career as he explained I couldn't
wrap my brain around some of the sides
because you know in your reading for
these high-level projects there's never
really any specificity in the sides
everything's like super vague everything
is in secret reading through I just
couldn't connect it I definitely bombed
that one for sure in the end 2015 was a
mixed year for Jordan while he punched
his way into the collective
consciousness of the titular protagonist
in Creed he also starred as Johnny Storm
and The highly publicized third
Fantastic Four perhaps a co-lead role in
Star Wars the Force awakens would have
helped to soothe the Sting from the
backlash of the latter movie play more
foreign
of Batman is a once in a lifetime
opportunity whenever there's a new bat
movie on the horizon rumor swirl over
who is in consideration for the part
before Ben Affleck put on the cape and
cow for Zack Snyder's Batman v Superman
dawn of Justice martial artists and
actress Scott Adkins stepped up for a
chance to become Gotham's protector
footage of Adkins audition tape leaked
out to the public in the clip the
British actor recites lines from The
Dark Knight Rises while sporting a
goatee the iconic look of its character
Yuri boykar from the Undisputed film
series Adkins may not have scored the
role but his audition at the fan base
discussing the possibilities while he
might not have been considered a serious
candidate since he was strictly a
B-movie actor at the time of casting he
certainly has the physique and martial
arts prowess to bring Batman to life on
the big screen plus he also Bears an
uncanny resemblance to Affleck something
that is parodied in his film accident
Man hitman's Holiday
while Timothy chalamet may be everywhere
and racking up big roles nowadays he had
his fair share of failed auditions when
he was Rising through the Hollywood
ranks even so he was knocking on all the
right doors and being invited into the
conversation at the 2018 Los Angeles
Film critics Association awards chalamet
was showered with praise for his
performance and call me by your name
while collecting his award he opened up
about how he had auditioned for
Spider-Man homecoming a few years
earlier as he explained I read twice and
I left sweating in a total panic I
called my agent Brian sorstrom and I
said Brian I thought about this a lot
and I have to go back and knock on that
door and read again in an effort to sway
him from doing so swordstrom recounted
the infamous story of how Sean Young put
on a Catwoman costume and appeared at
the studio in an attempt to convince her
decision makers for Batman Returns to
give her the role that stunt backfired
on Young and became a lesson of what not
to do in Showbiz ultimately Charlemagne
didn't get the role as it went to Tom
Holland
part of the reason that the office is
one of the most beloved sitcoms of all
time is because of the cast that
chemistry is through the roof and
everyone complements each other's
character in fact it's a kind of show
that no one could imagine being rebooted
without the original cast members
involvement yet the series wasn't a
lightning in a battle scenario where the
right people presented themselves from
the start there was a substantial
casting process where many actors came
in to read for the various parts on
offer one of the more interesting
auditions was Seth Rogen for the role of
Dwight Schrute Rogan's audition
demonstrates a different approach to
advice than what was portrayed by rain
Wilson not to take anything away from
Rogan's comedic sensibilities as he is
an accomplished actor and comedian in
his own right but it's tough to imagine
anyone other than Wilson as Dwight
judging by Rogan's audition he would
have been more of a passive aggressive
version of Dwight as opposed to Wilson's
outright aggressive character that had
manic Tendencies there's no disputing
their producers and casting team made
the correct Choice here
Scarlett Johansson is one of the most
prominent actors in the world she's
equally Adept at starring in
Blockbusters like the MCU films as she
is an Oscar Bay dramas such as marriage
story what some people may forget about
Johansen is that she had been acting
since she was quite young some of her
earlier roles include Parts in 1994's
north and 1997's home alone 3. however
she could have had a mega Blockbuster in
her early filmography had events turned
out differently Joe Hanson auditioned
for the role of Judy Shepard in Joe
Johnston's Jumanji but she lost out to
fellow child star Kirsten Dunst who was
on a scorching hot streak coming off
Interview with the Vampire and Little
Women while it might have taken Johansen
a little longer than duns to hit the
A-list league in Hollywood she
eventually did so in the 2000s
Laura Durham revealed it was Nicholas
Cage Who convinced her to speak to
director Steven Spielberg about Jurassic
Park she eventually landed the role of
Dr Ellie Sadler which she Revisited in
several sequels however she wasn't the
only actor approached for the part
audition tapes of sin surface showcasing
the likes of Helen Hunt and Gwyneth
Paltrow reading for Ellie Paltrow may
have thought that she had a foot in the
door since she worked with Spielberg a
few years earlier playing a younger
version of Wendy Darling in Hook
unfortunately for the Iron Man actor it
wasn't meant to be instead it was done
he received the opportunity to scream
bloody murder and run away from those
pesky Velociraptors in Jurassic Park
run really
Ron Howard's Backdraft boasts a superb
cast including Kurt Russell William
Baldwin Jennifer Jason Lee and Robert De
Niro and yet it almost had another big
name actor in the form of Brad Pitt in
fact if he had gotten the part it could
very well have kick-started his
Ascension to the upper echelons of
Hollywood much sooner in the early 1990s
pit was building up steam with small
parts whatever he could but the
opportunity to audition for the role of
Brian McCaffrey in Backdraft allowed him
to sink his teeth into something meatier
he wasn't the only notable name
competing for the part either audition
tapes have revealed that both Robert
Downey Jr and Keanu Reeves read for the
role as well but in the end Howard and
his team went for the Baldwin instead
clueless didn't only announce the
arrival of Alicia Silverstone as a star
but it also introduced the world to
Jeremy's sister who plays Elton in the
movie after the success of Clueless the
young castles in high demand and the
opportunities started to roll in for
them while Silverstone was cast as bad
girl in Joel Schumacher's Batman and
Robin sister received the opportunity to
audition for the part of Jack Dawson and
James Cameron's 1997 tearjerker Titanic
the role of Jack went to Leonardo
DiCaprio in the end however footage of
sisto's screen test with Kate Winslet
has since been released the actor has
also not been shy to discuss the
experience when asked about it he told
Live with Kelly and Ryan yeah it's one
of those are my failures it's a good
failure after this confession he went on
to explain a test screen for Leonardo's
role it was a big deal it was like a
full set wardrobe and makeup it was very
nerve-wracking I was 19.
who wouldn't want to be Spider-Man when
the opportunity to portray Marvel's web
Slinger presented itself after Sony
decided to reboot this series in the
2010s every actor under the age of 30
begged their agent to get them an
audition for The Amazing Spider-Man one
actor determined to get the gig was The
Hunger Game Star Josh Hutcherson and
well it wasn't exactly a total failure
of an audition in fact he was pretty
close to Landing the role after being
shortlisted for the part purchase and
spoke to Entertainment Weekly about what
it meant to him to even be a contender
he said the fact that I'm on the list
with some of the people that are on the
list I'm amazed that they're putting me
on that short list I think it's really
cool to be considered by the media to be
in the same category as all those other
people that have been considered it's
really a privilege ultimately Andrew
Garfield was cast as Spider-Man that
said Hutchison screen test leads onto
the internet showcasing his version of
Peter Parker engaging in combat with a
group of assailants its needs and
exciting footage proving he would have
also made an excellent choice for the
past
Bob Odenkirk is best known as Shady
lawyer Saul Goodman from Breaking Bad
and Better Call Saul but he started his
career in TV comedy writing and starring
in shows like Mr show and the Ben
Stiller show expect to Lee when the
office was searching for actors to
portray the lead role of Michael Scott
Odin Kirk auditioned for the part and
was taken extremely seriously as a
candidate when the sitcom was presented
to NBC Odin Kirk was actually presented
as Michael however the producers were
still hopeful that their main pick Steve
Carell will become available as luck
would have it and bad news for Odin Kirk
Corral's sitcom Come to Papa received
the ax and he was able to take the part
of Michael it doesn't appear as if there
are any sour grapes about how matters
turned out though since Odin Kirk did
appear in the ninth season of the office
as Mark Franks A Riff on Michael's
character